I'm wondering about some random symptoms and weather. They could be related in point to the system systematic secondary infection or a balance.
Last week, Zulma acquired about red streaks first noticed in January 2023.
My legs and torso that come and go lasted only a few hours at a time.
You mentioned the possibility of live disease.
I have not gone through your live course, but by symptoms and photos are lighted doesn't match well.
A description of a limb and gytus, which which can be true too, you can have inflammation of different things too.
Kind of fit so that that may be true. So you could diagnostic picture of that when we helpful.
Though I have no open wounds streaks tend to go toward away from my groin and armpits.
I do have swollen lymph nodes also. So swollen lymph nodes also could talk about possibility of infection as well.
Also in the last week, I've had trouble with urination with urgency of urination.
There's not the pressure of a full-blown uti, but my first need to go is desperate.
I would want to know, I don't know who does it ask this question, I want to know your age.
As we age, you know, you might have had a history of, you know, utis once or twice or five times in the past.
As we age, we tend to lose a lot of those symptoms of uti and the only symptom that we have is urgency.
And then as we get a little older, we can almost get a little delirious.
And that is your first side of your over 65 and you have a little urgency and a little kind of cloudy thinking.
People are like, are you okay?
You have to think of uti and many times you will get any uti symptoms, even if you have history of uti.
So you know what those symptoms are.
If you have a first need to go and it's desperate like, oh my gosh, you're going to run to the bathroom.
You know, you can, you know, you guys, you can go buy an Amazon, a urinary test trip kit and it comes with like 50 little dipsticks and you just go pee in a cup and you can test it yourself and see if there's any bacteria in there at least.
So that's what they would do in a doctor's office of the charge 50 bucks, you can buy the whole kit for 50 bucks and it gives you 50 strips.
So that's something you can get you can just buy those on Amazon.
Now, if you have a uti most likely, we'll see bacteria in your urine, but you also want to get a CBC.
So complete blood test, a CBC, complete blood count will give you white blood cell count and you'll have a slightly elevated white blood cell if you have an infection as well.
Also, if you're thinking you have an infection outside of the urinary tract, you won't see it on a urinary dipstick.
Typically, you wouldn't get swallowed and lived out with a uti, but anything is possible.
If you have any inflammation of your live system of your masculitis or something like that, that's a concern as well, but you would see that on a CBC.
And it elevated white blood cell count. I've been doing coffee animals every day since December could less than Heidi, animal provoke a uti, no.
So unless you're putting it in the wrong place.
So, no, that you should watch, you should be watching your animal tube out well, just soap and water and rinsing it really good, you're be fired with that.
So, you just, you're that just wouldn't work that way.
And I've had a perpetual earache and sore throat since the fall of 2021.
Okay, well, we really should, I mean, I don't, I don't know if you've had recent blood work or not.
Hold on one second, because I just added a, I just added a test to our Rupa store.
And I wanted to get the name of it and tell you.
So stick with me, I'm searching our Rupa store right now. Why isn't it showing?
I have to do it again.
But I just added what's called what I named a simple CBC and CMP. And it's like 50 bucks.
So it just keeps it less expensive for you to get a simple CBC and complete metabolic panel or inexpensive.
It's not showing on the Rupa store right now. So I have to redo it.
I don't think it's saved my changes.
So it's simple to get that test if your doctor will do it for you under your insurance.
I was diagnosed with Hashimoto's 20 years ago. I have not been very symptomatic sense for hair loss, which increased a few years ago.
Now the last week or two hair losses become extreme.
So things that will flare your Hashimoto's.
So if you still have antibodies, um, thyroid globular antibodies or TPO antibodies, you still have Hashimoto's.
Typically those don't go away. Sometimes they can go into remission and you can be fine for a very long time.
And then they can flare up again. What can flare your auto view disease? Well, the truth is, anything, anything can flare your auto view disease.
I do give, I have several videos in.
I think it's sections or module seven of the auto view course is solely on Hashimoto's. It's all the latest information and Hashimoto's.
You could look up some videos on there and I do have some videos on what can flare an auto view disease.
Um, do latest research. The last couple of years, I'll tell you salt can be a huge flare. So if you're
salty, your food iodide can be a huge flare of Hashimoto's. But if you're taking iodide, you want to cut that out.
But I have a list of a whole bunch. I mean, literally a whole, anything can flare your, your auto view disease.
By any of these related or pointed to an infection, I would definitely get a CBC to make sure you don't have any infection.
And send me the results of that. So, yep, run a CBC.